bonjour merci de nous rejoindre dans
file echo l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition
de l'actualité cette semaine immobilier
d'entreprise le nouvel easy est un
campus d'entreprise dernière génération
construit sur le pôle tertiaire de
vélizy-villacoublay il est loué pour
neuf ans par le groupe thales nous
l'avons visitée vous connaissez les noms
de domaine français ou point fr ce n'est
pas une entreprise mais une association
qui les administrent elle est peu
implanté depuis sa création à saint
quentin en yvelines
elle y a même inauguré ses nouveaux
locaux on vit c'est une entreprise avec
un projet économique sociale et
solidaire implantée à trappes depuis
deux ans l'entreprise connaît un certain
succès illustre les possibilités de
cette économie c'est notre portrait de
la semaine
enfin dans notre entretien cette semaine
nous parlerons du réseau à venir 78 née
il ya un an le réseau fait le a fait le
pari de réunir quatre associations pour
développer le tissu de l'économie
sociale et solidaire nous en parlerons
avec sophie ollier bonjour vous êtes
coordinatrice des interventions
pédagogiques pour l'association y est
vous avez supervisé aussi ce projet nous
reviendrons donc avec vous sur le bilan
du réseau à venir soit 118 mais avant
cela nous avons passé en revue
l'actualité de la semaine
immobilier d'entreprise
un nouveau campus pour le groupe thales
vendredi dernier le groupe électronique
spécialisé dans l'aérospatial la défense
et les technologies de l'information a
inauguré son nouveau campus à vélizy un
concept de deux campus urbain très
moderne mais aussi respectueux de
l'environnement le groupe a signé un
bail de neuf ans pour cet édifice
véritable vitrine pour le pôle
d'activités tertiaires de vélizy
villacoublay tatry tags de dit patrick
jacques de dixmude pardon et guillaume
l'ont visitée pour nous respectueux de
l'environnement et du bien-être des
salariés c'est ainsi qu'est décrit le
campus ni vélizy 2500 salariés du groupe
thalès vont bientôt intégrer cet espace
situé dans innover lé parc
le pôle d'activité de vélizy
villacoublay construit en caux
partenariat entre foncière des régions
et crédit agricole assurances le campus
n'a pas bénéficié d'investissements du
groupe thales il est seulement locataire
du site
la location a deux avantages le premier
avantage pour moi c'est un avantage
économique
il est il est tout à fait clair que je
préfère supporter un bail sur durée de
neuf années les gars autour des
rendements que peuvent apporter le
marché immobilier
il est préférable que la capacité
d'investissement de thales à y portent
sur le notre core business plutôt que
sur les investissements immobiliers deux
ans de travaux ont été nécessaires pour
produire ses 46 mille mètres carrés de
bureaux répartis sur trois bâtiments un
investissement 292 millions d'euros
la demande de location en ile de france
représentait fin septembre 1,5 million
de mètres carrés soit une progression de
13% sur un an
la conjoncture permet une plus grande
marge de manoeuvre est plus d'exigences
pour les entreprises locataires
aujourd'hui les grands groupes ont
plutôt tendance effectivement être
locataires de leur immobilier ça leur
donne plus de flexibilité dans le temps
il faut savoir que sur ce site là on
aura consenti une capacité d'extension
de 10 mille mètres carrés dont thales
peut grossir sur ce site et on sera
peut-être amené à leur construire une
extension c'est ce qu'on a fait pour
dassault systèmes un petit peu plus loin
derrière donc et à ce moment là on sait
que thales est là pour plus de neuf ans
présent depuis plus de 30 ans sur le
site de vélizy le groupe thales va
installer sur le campus trois activités
l'avionique la division des systèmes
terrestres et l'ensemble des activités
support certifié hqe le haute qualité
environnementale new vélizy est un
nouvel atout pour innover lé parc
ça nous a permis avec l'afnor d'être la
ville pilote qui va permettre de
participer à la nouvelle norme qui vont
être les quartiers durables cartes et
d'affaires est donc là on est aussi très
fiers de participer à ça puisque il ya
trois villes majeures en france avec un
quartier d'affaires de bordeaux où un
autre quartier d'affaires de lyon et
vélizy et puis des villes chinoises et
américaines il nouvelles parts le pôle
vélizy-villacoublay accueille sur son
territoire plus de 1000 entreprises et
43 mille salariés sur 600 mille mètres
carrés de bureaux
associé avec le territoire de me dont il
est le deuxième pôle tertiaire
francilien et représente 13 % du parc de
bureaux dans les yvelines
la semaine dernière la fnic inaugurait
ses nouveaux locaux à montigny le
bretonneux en présence d'axel le maire
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique
alors l'afrique c'est l'association
française pour le nommage internet en
coopération
elle intègre des représentants des
pouvoirs publics des utilisateurs et
prestataires de services internet créé
en 1998 elle a été désigné par l'état
pour gérer les noms de domaine français
en point fr donc l'association est
implantée à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 2002 et elle fonctionne comme une
entreprise comme ont découvert anthony
rech et patrick jacques de dixmude une
nouvelle adresse pour l'afnic mais celle
ci n'est pas virtuel l'association a
inauguré ses nouveaux locaux
après 13 ans passés de rue george
stephenson à montigny le bretonneux
elle a investi l'immeuble d'en face
l'afnic existe depuis 1997 elle
fonctionne comme une pme et se charge de
plusieurs missions aux missions elles
sont d'abord techniques
il ya maintenant infrastructure
technique on a des techniciens des
architectes des ingénieurs beaucoup les
développeurs informatiques pour les
logiciels qui opère tout ça et puis nous
avons des fonctions de promotion du
point fr pour
rappeler que ça a du sens que ça permet
aux entreprises de s'adresser aux
français en français tous les noms de
domaine site internet ou adresse mail
finissant par point à faire sont
administrés par les énormes serveurs
informatiques de l'afnic situés partout
dans le monde
pourtant l'association reste garante de
l'identité française et pas uniquement
sur internet
on est complètement en france avec des
équipes internaliser en france qu'on
opère des infrastructures en france et
puis aussi on essaie de promouvoir le
fait qu' on peut réussir en point fr et
être fier d'être français et la fichiers
sur internet et que c'est un critère de
succès pour le développement de son
entreprise depuis son installation à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'afnic a
beaucoup grandi
aujourd'hui elle compte 80 employés ils
n'étaient que 35 à ses débuts un
développement qui va de pair avec la
croissance des noms de domaine en point
fr en 2001 il en existait trois cent
mille aujourd'hui on en recense près de
3 millions une dynamique qui ne devrait
pas s'essouffler notamment avec le
nouveau nom de domaine pons paris que
l'afnic vient de lancer et depuis le 9
septembre l'enregistrement des noms de
domaine en point paris est possible même
pour les particuliers c'est le résident
près de la capitale mais dépêchez-vous
bientôt il ne sera plus réservé
uniquement aux franciliens dans les
yvelines le réseau plato commerce s'est
achevée la semaine dernière la méthode
plateau mise en place par la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de france vise à
favoriser les chaises les échanges entre
les dirigeants de pme et les cadres de
grands groupes d'un même secteur
géographique
l'expérience a été un succès et les
commerçants yvelinois regrette qu'elle
se termine déjà un reportage de williams
elle comme daniela ils sont 47
commerçants yvelinois avoir bénéficié du
réseau plato pendant deux ans huit
cadres de grands groupes les hommes
coachés 70 ateliers leur ont été
proposées pour améliorer l'activité de
leur commerce et leur compétence pour
cet architecte et décoratrice
d'intérieur à la tête d'un atelier de
plusieurs collaborateurs
l'expérience s'est révélée positive
j'avais des méthodes que j'appliquais
mois bien sûr comme tout manager mais
j'avais aussi des méthodes que j'avais
oublié donc réseau plato m'a permis avec
avec les interventions de tous les mois
qu'on a eue de revenir sur les
fondamentaux pour la management d'une
équipe
ce réseau plato jeu
un peu comme en miroir qui vont permet
en fait de faire moi-même le point sur
ma façon de diriger ma façon de
concrétiser on va dire mes réalisations
améliorer ses compétences en management
en gestion ou communication mais pas
seulement
les réunions permettent également aux
entrepreneurs de rompre leur isolement
l'expérience a généré un véritable
réseau d'entreprise et a vu les échanges
se développer sur le territoire des
yvelines pourquoi doit-elle alors
s'arrêter
l'expérience prend fin parce que un
programme ça dure deux ans c'est comme
ça que c'est monté c'est selon la
méthode au plateau et en perspective
nous allons monter la très prochainement
novembre un groupe sur le plateau
international qui sera donc lié à une
thématique et en début d'année 2015 un
plateau sur le territoire de la boucle
de seine avec plusieurs groupes donc en
fait les groupes tournent et
l'expérience est bien loin de s'achever
après ses deux ans 92 % des participants
se sont dits satisfaits du dispositif
plateau je vous en parlais la semaine
dernière le premier salut des
mampreneurs des yvelines a eu lieu à
versailles le 7 et le 10 novembre
toutes les mamans adhérentes de
l'association se sont retrouvés pour
faire découvrir leurs activités et aussi
pourquoi pas faire naître des vocations
de nombreuses mamans ainsi que des
professionnels sont d'ailleurs venus à
cette première édition pour nouer de
nouveaux contacts
elodie moines étaient sur place on s'est
mis à plusieurs on a motivé les copines
et puis on a essayé de donner une
certaine unité
pour que chacun puisse s'y retrouver et
puisse montrer son activité on voulait
vraiment que ce soit sur sur deux jours
on voulait que tout le monde y participe
deux jours pour bien pour bien
s'investir et pour qu'on puisse vraiment
montré toute l'étendue de nos activités
les mampreneurs des yvelines espèrent
accueillir encore plus de visiteurs pour
une deuxième édition de leur salon qui
pourrait avoir lieu dès l'année
prochaine
il est maintenant temps de passer à
notre entretien de la semaine
pour notre entretien de la semaine je
vous disais en titre dont nous avons
parlé d'économie sociale et solidaire
sophie olivier vous êtes avec nous je
vous est je le rappelle coordinatrice au
sein de l'association y est vous avez
donc participer au développement du
projet à venir 78 mais avant de passer
un entretien jeu nous allons regarder ce
qui s'est passé en fait cette semaine
dont les yvelines dans le cadre du mois
de l'économie sociale et solidaire
aujourd'hui les acteurs associatifs
étaient conviés à la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux des
ateliers et tables rondes ont eu lieu
l'occasion pour les différents acteurs
de rencontrer et d'échanger notamment
avec les experts sur les problèmes
rencontrés dans le milieu associatif
l'objectif était de rassembler ces
associations pour qui elles partagent
leurs ressources et mobilisent leurs
compétences autour d'un projet commun
celui du développement de l'économie
sociale et solidaire sur le territoire
et coûté ces précisions recueillies par
brouillard elle s'avoue partie de nos
missions d'essayer de
d'apporter aux associations des outils
parce que parce qu'aujourd'hui ils ont
besoin d'eux
dis pas seulement 2
de financement parce qu'elle manque de
bénévoles c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
associations ont du mal à recruter des
bénévoles dirigeants donc essayer de
voir ensemble comment on peut partager
ce bénévole et puis mettre en commun des
projets est de plus en plus les
associations ressentent le besoin de
travailler collectivement alors ses
lèvres ce pionnier vous avez vu cette
réunion en quoi cela est utile pour des
acteurs comme vous des associations des
acteurs associatifs
c'est ces rencontres en fait permettent
de pouvoir échanger sur les différentes
différentes difficultés pour qu'on peut
rencontrer au quotidien mais aussi aussi
les forces et les atouts qu'on peut
qu'on peut avoir et du coup de pouvoir
s'enrichir les uns des autres de nos
enfants de nos expériences
donc c'est
dans l'économie sociale et solidaire une
des particularités c'est qu'on essaie
toujours de trouver des façons
innovantes de créer une entreprise de la
développer et du coup la coopération est
une des valeurs fondamentales de l'urss
et pour ça le meilleur moyen de coopérer
c'est justement de se rencontrer de
d'échanger sur nos pratiques et devoirs
voilà comment on peut s'inspirer les uns
des autres ce soutien les uns des autres
pour pouvoir développer des fautes les
projets qu'on défend alors ça ça
ressemble ça s'apparente au dispositif
du monde à venir 78 alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous rappeler ce que ce qui
est justement ce dispositif à venir 78
alors où tout départ ça a été une
volonté donc de quatre acteurs
associatifs accompagné d'institutions
publiques comme la direccte alors les
quatre acteurs je le rappelle donc il y
donc qui est en charge de la
coordination et de la communication du
programme et de la création du réseau
mais aussi bg&e yvelines qui elle assure
des formations notamment pour les
missions locales je résume un petit peu
yvelines active qui est un acteur
central du financement de ss qui
s'occupe qui produit également une base
de données des structures de l'économie
sociale et solidaire et profession sport
78 qui organisait 15e réunion
d'information sur les contrats aidés
c'est ça alors alors ces actions là elle
rentrait dans le cadre du dispositif à
venir 78 donc ces associations le point
commun c'est qu'elles ont toutes un
moment donné dans leurs projets elle
vise tout l'accompagnement des
structures de l'économie sociale et
solidaire nous ça va être dans la
communication dans la valorisation de
leurs actions mais à venir sont 18 ça va
être à venir son histoire il est inactif
ça va être sur l'aspect financier
du développement de ces entreprises même
si on est entreprise d'économie sociale
et solidaire à venir vge yvelines et
profession sport font aussi de
l'accompagnement mais j'eus plus sur la
création d'entreprises et professions
sport enfin non plus spécifique au
milieu associatif sur comment se
structurer et du coup au départ c'était
comment comment pouvoir nous travaillent
ensemble pour proposer un accompagnement
des du tissu associatif et l'économie
sociale et solidaire 78 qu'ils soient
plus structuré et permettre un
développement de le ss sur le sur le
territoire est ce qu'il pouvait juste je
me permets de vous couper mais ont
rappelé un petit peu globalement de
façon un peu simple fait qu est ce qui
est exactement l'économie sociale et
solidaire pour les gens qui ne
connaissent pas gros challenge
d'expliquer ce qu'est l'économie sociale
et solidaire en fait
le scn plutôt une manière de penser
l'entreprise
donc au niveau
aujourd'hui maintenant il ya une loi
cadre qui va là qui va définir ce que
c'est que l'économie sociale et
solidaire mais c'est d'abord comment une
entreprise va fonctionner avec certains
piliers forts comme les entreprises qui
ont une gouvernance participative qui
ont une utilité sociale dans leur projet
en tout cas qui vont s'implanter dans un
territoire pour faire vivre le tissu
local
voilà
c'est nier qu'il ya aussi un côté de
l'écologie et au développement durable
alors il ya eu en fait ça va dans le
sens justement du développement durable
parce que là c'est l'idée d'aussi de
créer une une
des ressources collectives en gros c'est
aussi de travailler pas pour un profit
personnel mais un profit collective
vient de tous voilà après dans les
structures qui en font partie des avoirs
les coopératives les associations les
scop les coopératives donc concédé une
coopérative c'est toutes les formes de
coopératives soient scop scs là il y en
a beaucoup alors un spa et on parle
toujours avec beaucoup de sigles mais il
va y avoir aussi tout ce qui toutes les
mutuelles les mutuelles et également les
fondations qui sont là pour pour le
soutien soutien de projets d'utilité
sociale et donc pourquoi c'est donc ces
quatre associations dont à vous vous
êtes dit alors on va se mettre ensemble
pour faire naître ce disposition ce
dispositif alors
je sais plus exactement quelle année
mais ça doit être aux alentours de 2012
à peu près
naïli sied dès la réalisation de
diagnostic de territoire alors yves
inactifs par exemple à réaliser un
diagnostic sur l'ensemble du département
noah y à la demande de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on a réalisé
ce diagnostic sur saint quentin en
yvelines pour faire un état des lieux de
l'urss sur notre territoire où on en est
2 le ss sur nos territoires
quelle part ça représente en terme
d'emploi en termes d'activité etc
du coup pour voir comment on pourrait
améliorez améliorer le développer voir
que le ss au niveau national c'est à peu
près 10% de l'emploi dans les yvelines
on s'aperçut qu'on était en dessous
alors je sais plus exactement les
chiffres mais je crois qu'au niveau du
département on a à peu près aux
alentours de 6% qu'on me semble ce
serait quand même à vérifier et
et du coup on a aussi on s'est aussi
aperçu qu'il y avait des manques en
termes d'accompagnement des structures
et des porteurs de projet nome et
comment ça s'explique par exemple dans
les yvelines qui a moins de projets de
l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est dû
à quoi vous savez alors après je pense
que c'est assez différent selon selon
les territoires
là où ça entre guillemets sannois un peu
le prince on sait que par exemple sur la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il ya beaucoup
de d'entreprises qui ont leur siège
social il ya beaucoup de zones
d'activités où il ya du coup beaucoup
d'entreprises du secteur économique
classique donc forcément c'est honda par
comptant beaucoup d'emplois la part de
le ss revient plus nakba ce c'est en
termes c'est un pourcentage
il ya des des zones plus rurales où il
ya beaucoup de coopératives agricoles
donc du coup forcément vu quatre dans
ces endroits là est aussi moins d'autres
secteurs d'activité en termes de
pourcentages l'activité plus important
bref justement je connais pas forcément
toutes les toutes les raisons elles sont
pas toujours simples à une en 10e et en
tout cas une des causes qu'on a été
notifiée c'était qu' il y avait peu de
d'endroits où deux personnes identifiées
vraiment pour accompagner des porteurs
de projets des gens qui dit voilà moi
j'ai envie de monter mon entreprise vers
qui je m'adresse pour avoir de l'aide
alors ific
nous en tant que les quatre associations
dont on a parlé on
on est assez identifier là dessus mais
vu qu'on ne travaille pas forcément ne
travaillez pas forcément tout le temps
ensemble
bah ça pouvait paraître un peu floue
pour quelqu'un qui ne connaissait pas ce
secteur d'accord et donc au bout d'un an
la de concertation vous êtes dit
quelques allons nous mettre en place
quels vont être les prochaines étapes
donc pour le dispositif à venir 70 voilà
en fait il ya un an donc c'était en
novembre dernier on a lancé fait le
lancement de ce dispositif et dans ce
dispositif c'était donc un plan d'action
sur un an
on avait du coup le soutien de plusieurs
plusieurs enseignes ont claqué ce qui va
se passer les prochaines les prochaines
étapes
les prochaines étapes l'a déjà c'est
faire le bilan des différentes actions
qu'on a mis en place donc que vous avez
rénumérés tout à l'heure les formations
les réunions d'information l'action de
concertation pour initier la mise en
place d'un réseau des acteurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
donc maintenant ce qui va se passer
c'est que tous ces acteurs qui ont pu se
rencontrer et qui ont pu échanger sur
ces problématiques de le ss dans les
yvelines vont continuer à se réunir donc
là il va y avoir il ya un groupe de
travail qui a été initiée avec duke ou
encore d'autres associations celles déjà
présentes plus d'autres qui vous
continuez à être à travailler sur un
plan d'action à mettre en place pour
vraiment construire le réseau et faire
en sorte que plus de structures
possibles y adhèrent et et continue à
promouvoir le ss au près correctement
eh bien merci sociaux liés d'être venu
sur notre plateau nous n'arriverons
maintenant poursuivre maintenant de près
notre émission avec le chiffre de la
semaine
alors nous restons sur le thème de
l'économie sociale et solidaire 32 1885
c'est le nombre d'emplois dans le
secteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire en est divine parmi ces
emplois plusieurs activités regroupent
recrute la santé les activités
financières et l'enseignement pour 19%
les actions sociales reste le plus gros
employeur avec 41 % des emplois soit
plus de 13 mille cinq cents personnes
qui travaillent dans ce secteur de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
ces chiffres viennent de l'observatoire
régional de l'économie sociale et
solidaire franciliens en ile de france
près de 398 personnes travaillent dans
le secteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
je vous propose maintenant de passer à
notre portrait de la semaine nous
continuons sur le même thème les mêmes
thèmes pardon cette semaine je vous
propose de découvrir une jeune
entreprise en pleine croissance
l'entreprise envie située à trappes
existe depuis deux ans elle fonctionne
sur le principe de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
elle s'appuie sur le réseau envie un
réseau d'entreprises qui existe depuis
30 ans et qui est national
le réseau agit contre l'exclusion pour
l'économie sociale et pour la protection
de l'environnement à trappes laventure
envie connaît déjà un certain succès et
se développe
regardez ce reportage de william el est
romand respini s'en relever
un atelier comme il en existe beaucoup
pourtant celui là est un peu spécial ici
attrapons de produits rien on répare
collecter les appareils électroménagers
défectueux leur donner une seconde vie
pour les vendre moins cher
c'est ce que fait envie d'être l
opérateur vous voyez sont en contrat
d'insertion au chômage depuis une longue
période
ici leur met un pied dans le monde
professionnel pour félix c'est une
transition avant de retrouver un autre
emploi il travaille depuis un mois et
demi pour entreprises sociales et
solidaires
j'ai un bts productique mécanique et je
peux retourner dans la conception
industrielle donc voilà la sepr en
attendant ça m'aide à à financer d'avoir
un travail de remplir mon cv sur tôt
nous aide beaucoup là pour repartir dans
le marché du travail
c'est le même horaire c'est pareil si
les 35 heures on n'est pas là pour
produire mais voilà qu'à retourne à la
boîte un salarié reste au maximum deux
ans chez envie le roulement instaurer
leur permet d'approfondir leurs
compétences en s'essayant à différentes
tâches certains n'ont pas de
connaissances en électronique ou
mécanique avant de rentrer dans
l'atelier
le recrutement se fait essentiellement
sur la motivation et les demandes sont
nombreuses pour un emploi proposé une
dizaine de personnes se présentent on
essaie d'avoir un moral excellent de nos
opérateurs pour qu'ils soient le plus
performant possible puisqu'en fait le
but c'est vraiment l'idée d'équiper moi
je suis dans un camp je recrute des
opérateurs des gens dans le zap dans le
système fonctionne en atelier je
recherche du bon esprit pédagogie
accompagnement sur la formation et sur
le social les axes essentiels sur
lesquels travaillent en vie pourtant son
fonctionnement est identique à celui
d'une jeune entreprise traditionnelle et
le succès est au rendez vous après
seulement deux ans d'existence elle se
développe déjà de sept salariés en
insertion à ses débuts elle est passée à
17 aujourd'hui
jean-jacques le magasin aurait besoin
d'une cuisinière électrique avec des
plaques quatre feux et en fonte des
croissances de l'ordre de 15 à 20 % sur
les derniers mois ce qui est assez assez
conséquent surtout dans le contexte
économique actuel donc à la fois sur le
plan social sur le plan environnemental
puisque aussi on développe nos collectes
de déchets électroménagers
cette année on va collecter environ 1200
tonnes de déchets électroménagers et sur
le plan économique avec une progression
du chiffre d'affaires on voit qu'on est
dans la bonne direction
chaque jour une centaine de produits et
collecté 15 à 20 % d'entre eux peuvent
être réparés puis vendus en magasins les
prix affichés sont entre 40 et 50% moins
chers que ceux des produits neufs un
argument de taille pour convaincre les
consommateurs de plus en plus sensibles
à cette démarche sociale et solidaire
quand on fait de l'insertion avec des
personnes et qui puisse au moins
travailler et les lancers de la vie
active c'est vachement important quoi
donc si nous on peut contribuer pourquoi
pas malgré tout on s'aperçoit
qu'aujourd'hui on est en temps de crise
que les gens ont des petits budgets et
qu'ils réfléchissent beaucoup plus avant
d'investir dans d'électroménager
d'acheter du neuf dans les grandes
surfaces
est ce qu'ils s'aperçoivent que il ya
une obsolescence programmée de la part
des constructeurs qui fait que même en
achetant d'occasion il peut avoir des
produits qui dureront aussi longtemps et
pour bien moins cher
la consommation est bien plus
responsable aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
l'était il ya 20 ou 30 ans
dernière née du réseau envie
l'entreprise de trappes a un objectif
mensuel de vente d'environ 45 mille
euros elle espère atteindre son
équilibre financier l'année prochaine et
ouvrir très prochainement un deuxième
magasin dans paris il est temps de
passer à l'agenda de la semaine
et cette semaine de rendez vous à ne pas
manquer à la france est le deuxième
producteur européen de jeux vidéo et le
secteur recrute
si vous êtes attiré par cet univers
sachez que la cité des métiers de saint
quentin organise le mardi 18 novembre de
10 heures à midi une réunion
d'information sur les métiers des jeux
vidéo il sera animé par des
professionnels de capital games un
syndicat national du jeu vidéo
à noter qu'il faut souscrire pour
participer enfin la ville de coignières
en partenariat avec le pôle emploi et la
confédération générale du patronat des
petites et moyennes entreprises des
yvelines organise leur douzième journée
de recrutement 40 recruteurs seront donc
présents le jeudi 20 novembre de 9h30 à
17h au salon antoine de saint-exupéry
après nerfs si vous souhaitez plus
d'informations n'hésitez pas à contacter
le service municipal économie et emploi
de la ville
merci de nous avoir suivis je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de file echo je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée